what's happening there reject nation the
whip thwip i mean because we got some
spider-man no way home to talk about oh
my god last night
wait yeah less than two weeks less than
two weeks friday as we're shooting this
okay guys well we got two things to talk
about today first thing is we're gonna
do a reaction to this thing called
andrew garfield teaser i'm sure it's
more of a reference or alluding towards
and second thing is we got some new
posters to look at so let's do them both
in one video anywho guys make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell if you can go ahead and hit that
like button if you enjoy our video
that'd be great as tony the lucky charm
says let's get to it starting off with
this teaser
[Music]
what's happening
visitors from every universe over here
or
my old friend spiderman
hey
good friend multiverse is real
[Music]
andrew garfield because he hasn't had
any encounters with tom holland thus far
and i suppose that completely wipes that
off the table that theory this jamie
foxx is actually one from the mcu
already established so he's a new one
yeah that makes it a clear-cut
acknowledgement that that is indeed the
one from the andrew garfield universe
and now i'm just hoping that when he
does finally see tom holland he gets to
say you're not peter parker and then
eventually norman osborne also gets to
say wait you're not peter
everyone gets a chance to do it
eventually i also like the way this
teaser was assembled this like social
media tv spot version where it's like
something that's your slingering yeah
coming through the sling ring that's
really neat the multiverse opening it's
cool to know that he's going to be in it
we already knew that
we all know it just again we're inching
towards the confirmation line that's the
journey right now
now let's look at these posters first
one on the list here okay what do we got
nice green goblin that looks so comical
it looks like out of the
mysterio nightmare illusion sequence and
far from home doesn't it yeah absolutely
like just in a black void filled with
smoke and nightmares there's a sense of
like imposing scale to goblin in this
shot well yeah and it's like even though
it's the classic costume it looks
somehow beefier just because of how
they've framed it and how they've chosen
their focal length and the glow coming
off the pumpkin bomb it's like a taunt
with the pumpkin bomb yeah
yeah oh that's sexy that's very sexy i
like it a lot like that just for my own
personal yeah i like the smoke mist as
if it's coming through in that very
moment right there because i like the
way he holds it it's just like i'm gonna
get you yeah exactly he's playing with
his food the heart we go after his heart
clear doc aquin looking looking like out
of a video game that looks like a ps5
graphic that does it's like a weird
compliment to give it it doesn't look
like a real capture one but it looks
like damn good
4k
it looks like damn good ps5 graphics
doesn't it yeah yeah he's not as de-aged
as i guess i was expecting on this
poster given when he's supposed to have
been plucked out of his universe but you
know it still looks like it's such a
nice just head-on shot of him and he's
got a lot of you know personality in his
expression they're really capturing the
doctor's side to ock yeah yeah he's
about to operate with his tentacles
right yes
it does feel like when they update a
video game or they give a dlc skin
version like oh spiderman they're doing
the remastered version yeah
now he's gonna look like alpha molly you
know this time
it looks like
these are all sexy and then jb fox these
are all so striking damn these are good
ass photos with that clear shot of the
ark reactor if your eye never looked
down during those shots in the trailer
there's a confirmation for you that is a
very clear-cut shot of the arc reactor
my goodness hey man everybody's gonna
get some stark tech by the end of this
movie that'll be good but hey i mean
jamie foxx he's all yellowed out
definitely i'm really curious the more
that they show us and the more they go
down that route how they're going to
just orchestrate and you know relish in
the transformation all these characters
must have to go through yes you know i
mean jamie foxx is getting a lot more
badass as this movie goes i'm glad
people are excited for jamie foxx
because a lot of people consider the
amazing spider-man 2 the worst one out
of all the spider-man movies i'm glad
people are excited for him he deserves
another shot and then what else we got
here oh my god there's an even cooler
poster that we didn't even see at the
moment of filming look at this awesome
ass international poster it looks
straight out of into the spider verse
but dour and moody like a sad holiday
christmas season oh the attention to
detail the artwork he's surrounded by
the gloomy despairing nightmarish
holiday spirit at hand before he gets
visited by villains of christmas past
my max poster swinging at the top there
i think there's actually also a super
wide version of this really yeah let's
check it out oh very cool i love the
webbing and just the whole like
yeah it's almost like a super fish eye
but also you know it's just reality
warped from dr strange the reflection on
the you know this puddle here in the
foreground like it's a very striking
image oh that's beautiful wow there's
just so much coming out right now
there's so much coming out you know what
i caught on twitter earlier today
actually i want to share this with you
guys i thought this was hilarious so
graham norton one of the best talk show
hosts ever of all time he um
tom holland and zendaya on the show
and uh i followed him on twitter and
then this got released i don't know if
you've seen this yet johnny oh goody i
don't maybe i probably haven't nara or
is it graham norton all right so
spiderman no way i'm starting someday
and tom holland and he used a photo of
this that he's promoting them to come on
the show and he's the photo of all three
spider-man at the same time
i yo man i mean i don't know if he knows
but i know he's poking the for the porn
at snack
he's poking the bear with this oh he's
having a blasty blast absolutely when
was the last time he had andrew garfield
on the show
i don't know i mean
boom just came out i mean
you know he might have some secrets and
the last thing one rewatching spider-man
2 i always forget elizabeth banks is in
those movies i believe she actually
originally did audition for mary jane
that she got cast as betty brandt
instead who is now way more popular in
the mcu than elizabeth banks ever was
but she posted this photo here saying me
with my tickets this spider-man no way
home already throwback thursday i love
this i love seeing the support from fans
of the older movies even kirsten dunst
recently just spoke out saying that she
would love to return meaning she's
probably not in this movie
but if you guys do another one please
please call me invite me and i would
love to be a part of it yeah i would
love to see them both show up i would
love to see betty brantz on screen why
not that would be incredible all right
guys thank you so much for being here
this is so fun covering this i'm going
to miss the anticipation hype and then i
can't wait to see what doors this
spider-man multiverse opens so excited
so excited leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that bell hit that
like button
fleb doran phleb
i'm going to correct what we did
last month we shouted you out in the
video and your response was
i don't know what a striga is do you
know what striga is it's that spider
demon thing from the witcher
see
we screwed up we screwed up we screwed
up
sorry because you usually want to shout
out on a marvel related video well here
it is today man you're getting the shout
out that you absolutely deserve because
you comment on so many things you are so
inquisitive you are so supportive you
make christmas feel like it's all year
round you're our little mrs claus
that's what you are you don't want mrs
claus it's the gift that keeps on giving
i want you to like bake me some cookies
flat
come on give me a hug i want to eat out
your cookie yeah
you're a cookie i did it all for the
cookie i want to eat out your chocolate
chip cookie yeah
or maybe like a good muffin or how about
like yeah
put your brownie in my mouth yeah i get
that brown pound
i'm talking about some eggnog on my face
i want flat poop
merry christmas christmas
[Music]